we begin this morning with what one
military official is calling a miracle a
charter flight with a hundred
forty-three people on board slid off a
runway at Naval Air Station Jacksonville
in Florida and into a river but everyone
on board made it off alive and in good
condition the Navy says the Boeing 737
was carrying military personnel and
civilians from the US naval base at
Guantanamo Bay Cuba some of the
passengers were scheduled to travel on
to other naval bases from Jacksonville
the plane came to a stop in a shallow
part of the st. Johns River with a
half-hour dozens of military civilian
rescuers were on the scene some making
their way to the plane by boat
our crews went in the water immediately
to the wing edge and started escorting
people that were on the wing edge to the
shore 21 people were taken to hospitals
with minor injuries cleanup crews are
working this morning to contain the jet
fuel that is leaking into the river
there's no word on what caused the plane
to end up in the river and there was
stormy weather in the area at the time
federal air safety investigators are due
in Jacksonville today